back then everybody was doing features
they was going to order film festivals
and it was making no money I was like
none keep making the film festivals Rich
I'm going to make some money too and
that's what I did
Antoine your first film costs 25 000 to
me your Life's too short and it's a
feature right yeah and you made how much
from it
s 80k
so you were able to essentially more
than triple your money
okay how does that happen well for me
it's movie for me is I did a lot more
information sure I did a lot I went like
on a tour with that film
and Nassau merch at the film festivals
uh the livestreet short merch so I did a
lot of festivals I won like over 20
Awards so I sold merchants and festivals
um I did a lot of commands and yeah
they're really good for me and so these
premieres they were all in the New York
area yeah New York I did some um in
South Carolina but mostly in New York oh
so you travel what's in South Carolina
it was a festival I was at and they
really liked it and I brought it out
there it was oh it was good okay and so
how many screenings do you think you did
to make that eighty thousand probably
say like 25 30.
over what span of time six months
wow
so your life was just touring basically
with this film almost I would I won't do
it again but yes why why was it was a
lot of words calling theaters and trying
to get the right weight do the theaters
pay you back on time no so what I did
was I bought it out
so I bought the data out
um and then I just took the ticket sales
of food and all that yeah because I
don't want to do the whole
um wake for data anyone do that so I
just paid them out so if I used two days
I paid them up and I had my regular job
to pay for all the stuff
okay so then you were you were basically
the cashier at the door yep and then did
you use an online ticket service yes I
use event ticket or I use PayPal or
Eventbrite okay yeah great so three
different ways they could do it okay
great the movie itself cost twenty five
thousand you said where did the majority
of the budget go House actors
I pretty much it because what I did was
Life's Too Short you could watch it on
my website
um I use like two three houses that look
different upstairs announces
so I knew the homeowners so I used the
house it came a little money but really
just the locations and food and the
actors is pretty much it didn't cost me
a lot aside from the 25
000 to make the film Life's too short
how much did you have to spend on top of
that to then make this eighty thousand
um probably like another 25 Maybe
they're probably another 25 so datas and
everything yeah
theaters merch did you do food too yes
so some places okay so I got another 25
yeah and so I'm sorry you're so your
family's making this food
no some of my good families I have
friends oh all right oh I do like us
like so
in New York I know a lot of restaurant
owners so I could get a little money to
do a Katie range for the for the thing
and we do cross-promotion stuff like
that oh I see okay sometimes like if you
this is the rest of the mom's a Pot
restaurant they want some want some
promotion I might do like a little video
film like a promo video and we have a
little trade-off with food or I give
them a little money for the schools so
it's all about negotiating
okay and then some of the money you
because you were working at the time
were like for it so you had that you
were paying for these theaters or some
things okay can we break down how much
money came from the screenings versus
the soundtrack versus the merchandise
um
so like
so for the soundtrack I didn't even make
a lot of money off the soundtrack I mean
more money off the merch and the ticket
sales so the bulk of it came from ticket
sales and merch
um so
majority of it came from if you total
everything a majority came from the
merch in the ticket sales
and so you you kind of do a deep dive
into what you should be charging or do
you always charge like a set price I try
to stay at the 20 at that time I say at
the 20 Mark but now when I do my meds I
do more thirty dollars
did you license the movie or sell any
DVDs no it was straight um I even at the
time I said let me just do trainings I
wasn't thinking about that I just did I
didn't do none of that stuff nope I
should have done that but I didn't do it
what year was this
uh two thousand I would say 2005.
mm-hmm
2005 Okay so
what would you have done differently now
nothing
everything everything I did was what I
supposed to do because I was still
learning I was still learning because
because Life's Too Short what I did was
switching scissors was my first short I
went from a short to a feature
most people don't do that but I wanted I
felt confident so I did I didn't do a
whole bunch of shorts I did short
feature does the movie still make money
for you no
but it allows me was years ago and also
what it did was it built my confidence
up and I won a lot of awards like a lot
so when I pitch in I'm doing things
filmmaker it sounds nice so it did a lot
it
the most money it did for me was
experience because it really showed me
that I don't have to wait for nobody
I could literally do this
like I could do this with me and my team
we could knock this out so it gave me
just a lot of confidence
because everybody was doing back then
everybody was doing features they were
going to order film festivals and it was
making no money I was like none keep
making the film festivals Rich I'm going
to make some money too and that's what I
did
did you ever get your Festival
um a fees waived no I paid for I pay for
everything okay they never waived it
so let me see if I understand the
numbers then so you basically spent 25
000 to make the film and then you spend
another maybe 20 to get it out there on
the six month Festival run and then you
ended up making a total of eighty
thousand back over six months
how does somebody do that like
can can they do that over and over again
or it really had to be
certain movies certain crowds certain
times certain festivals yeah means a
little strategy so the strategy I had I
said listen for the first few months I'm
gonna do festivals because Festival take
a while to get back to you so when a
friend was getting back to me I was
winning the wars and everything I saw
lining it up okay I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna do that just to build the buzz up
and um
yeah it's all about the strategy of how
to do it because what happens is when
you submit to the festivals they don't
get back to like six four months later
they don't get back to you and I I so
when it would start getting back to me
because a lot of the times I submitted
to the festivals that was from January
to like uh around summertime
so once they start getting back to me
back to back I use that momentum to
start the tour because now it's winning
wars and everything I'm a winning
filmmaker so it's all about lying and
timing up have you ever thought about
writing a book actually my book comes
out next year at Christmas it called
stop asking for prevention and it's
basically about a lot of times you wait
for someone about this it's going to
stop asking for permission so I have 25
steps that's gonna yes I'm excited
very nice yeah
how many pages is the book this is sure
it's like 40 pages
[Music]
you just sell it on your own site or
you're going to go through I might go to
Amazon depends on the numbers because I
don't know how the numbers look like on
Amazon so I'm gonna see how the numbers
look but I will sell all copies on my
site too
much and then you can also do speaking
engagement style yeah I'm actually going
to do a short film that's attached to
the book called Lost Child and talk
about my childhood
um how I was lost and I found myself so
when I do the book signings I'm gonna
have a short film and part of it to get
the watch you short film that's another
thing about the business side so I'm
doing a book with a short film once
covet that's all I'm doing next year I
could do movie theaters with my short
film in the book
what did selling your first movie teach
you about the business
that
when people tell you you can't do
nothing
you showed them
like they really like it really gave me
so much confidence because when I was
doing the film I kept hearing oh if it's
not a big Network it's not gonna go
nowhere you don't have no stars in your
film who's gonna buy it you keep hearing
this industry talk because that's all
they know
that's the information you're gonna give
you guys so they know so once I realized
no I came from the music business
there's no different it's just a
different product
and that's you guys that's why this
industry or any industry don't believe
what they tell you write your own book
because they would tell you stuff that
make you feel like you little you
belittle you can't do this you can't do
that you could do a lot if you just
create your own world
create your own structure and it will
work out for you you just gotta trust
yourself
did you ever get advice from people that
were well-meaning they weren't trying to
tell you no but that
it just it just wasn't the answer you
wanted to hear I grew other times but I
have to realize once again I remember my
answer was your vision I'm pretty sure a
lot of people told them well you should
do this you do that because that's what
they know and a lot of times they
project and they fear on you so I don't
really
like yeah unless you actually doing
something that I feel like I don't I
really listen to most people
because I realize you know I keep people
around me and swallowing me they always
update me and stuff because usually if
you swipe Us in the room you're not
gonna learn nothing so always keep
people around there's no way more than
me and I know a lot too but um but yeah
you get that all the times it's just
people sometimes you're trying their
best they don't know they're just
telling you answers you should do this
but at the end of the day you gotta
trust yourself man
how can you tell when they're actually
they have your best interest in mind
versus they're trying to
stop you somehow and and
they're negative
um
I don't
yeah I'm at this point they just talk I
don't I might listen to them it depends
how it comes to me it depends on the
energy how they presented me and that's
what I know
um so it's all about Holiday Station it
comes to me okay so it's not really what
they say it's kind of PlayStation is how
they say it
was your first feature film a success
yes it was
how confident were you that you could
duplicate that success I was very
confident because I did it in the film
the music business and I knew
with anything
if I did this one time I could do it
again
and I was I was confident I won a whole
bunch of awards uh I remember when my
film likes you short got to the film
festival in Spain I never been Spain in
my life
I went out there and I seen that crowd
it was packed and I was like how like
how
and it's just it's the confidence one
day in my film festivals it really
builds your confidence and that would it
did for me that it's a zillion people in
this world a lot of times we focus on
industry people it's a zillion people in
this world he's got to find your market
and find your tribe
yeah because I was you know there's been
a lot of debate about film festivals and
whether they're worth it or not and is
it just for The Laurels but I like what
you're saying right here so it's not
just that it's not just to put Laurels
on a website it's that it builds your
confidence yeah it builds my confidence
up now is it worth it
um but when I was doing it it would
build my confidence up because you go
into all the different cities and state
you meet no people so they build my
confidence up I use it as a tool that's
Professor too you have to use these as a
tool it's not there forever so it's like
a two box you're gonna use your hammer
for the nails you're gonna use your
wrench for something else so festivals
is a tool don't get don't get stuck and
caught up in it
why not now because kovit
oh okay so if if things were open and oh
yeah it'd be it'd be still good but
covet
because now they have festivals online
that don't make no sense they charging
fees don't it's just the dumbest thing I
had a film festival for four years
called validate yourself I ended because
of covet because I did not I don't feel
comfortable charging filmmakers a fee to
watch it online that don't make no sense
to me um especially if you look at all
the movies out right now that's on
Netflix on the big or the big scratch
but another one got in film festivals
no one said you know what because this
Film Festival I want to watch this movie
you never hear that so now it doesn't
have the same power like it used to
I mean it's tough I mean there's great
films that you can watch online but at
the same time part of being at a
festival is is just hearing the audience
yeah it's a different experience right
right you can't you can't beat that
online stuff so with the films that do
it I don't
I shut my Festival down because I didn't
feel right doing paying charging fees
for online that made no sense